[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine un an de répétitions intenses et
25 artistes passionnés réunis sous un
chapiteau pour vous conter l'histoire de
monsieur barnum du 19 au 21 octobre
l'association réussir conte musical vous
entraîne dans son spectacle qui n'a pas
construit des mondes et des histoires
avec ses petites briques des passionnés
de l'association breezy en gagne une
exposition 100% légaux et vous accueille
ce week-end opéré en mousseline et
l'agenda complet devant sorties au
programme de la danse du golf et du
cinéma
vingt-cinq artistes pour raconter
l'histoire de phinéas taylor barnum le
créateur du cirque moderne aux états
unis unis dépensés par l'association le
cirque musical inspiré par le film c'est
proteste showman avec hugh jackman chine
et al
taylor barnum repérer des personnes
exclues de la société pour créer ces
shows une comédie musicale sous
chapiteau du 19 au 21 octobre à
versailles et la but caritatif écouter
[Musique]
pour ce projet nous avons souhaité aider
une association qui s'intitule loisirs
est progrès c'est une petite structure à
paris qui aide une vingtaine de
personnes qui ont vécu un traumatisme
crânien donc pour lequel le comme le
quotidien complètement changé soit par
leur mobilité soit par leurs souvenirs
aussi qu'ils ne sont plus comme avant un
rendez-vous 100% pour les enfants
pendant les vacances scolaires les
monuments nationaux mettent le
patrimoine hauteur des plus petits
ateliers visites sont spécialement
conçus pour eux et au château de
rambouillet le monument devient un jeu
d'enfant
anne claire des rôles bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes chargé des actions
éducatives du site est chez vous les
plus jeunes sont donc à des coûts sont
invités à découvrir l'envers du décor
exactement des sous du décor mais en
fait cette année donc monument jeu
l'enfance c'est vraiment une
manifestation qui a eu depuis plusieurs
années dans une quarantaine de monuments
dans toute la france et cette année au
château de rambouillet on a eu vraiment
envie de s'intéresser aux décors en tant
que vraiment objets plastiques et les
enfants on va les inviter à incarner un
peu le rôle de l'archéologue on va les
découvrir fouillé observé vraiment tous
ces décors on va essayer de les re
contextualiser un petit peu dans
l'histoire mais ce qui va nous
intéresser vraiment c'est les formes
c'est les textures les textures et ce
qu'ils aimeraient c'est vraiment voilà
découvrir tous ces décors qu'on peut
retrouver dans des demandes et aux
époques qui composent les salles du
parcours de visite du château et là
l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir deux
intervenantes qui vont encadrer les
enfants
donc il ya une plasticienne une peintre
plasticienne qui s'appelle véronique
arnaud qui est très très active dans le
78 elle est
elle a exposé d'ailleurs on veut cerner
récemment elle exposera au mois de mai à
chevreuse
on a également une conteuse qui
animatrice du patrimoine au service
éducatif du château qui va être là pour
essayer de faire découvrir ces décès
décor tout en les remettant un petit peu
dans l'histoire et à elles deux elles
vont créer tout un discours pour ouvrir
les yeux et ouvrir le regard un petit
peu différemment sur ses décors et
ensuite un atelier pourront réaliser
leur propre décor à partir de ce qu'ils
auront eux c'est ça ils vont venir même
créateur et peut-être repartis avec leur
château de rambouillet heureusement
voilà au moins une belle partie d'un
décor et qu'ils auront à intégrer
eux-mêmes en fait quand vous dites que
vous allez revenir sur l'histoire ça va
être une histoire en particulier parce
que château de rambouillet existe depuis
de nombreuses années et il a vu évoluer
l'histoire de france alors c'est là en
fait vraiment l'intérêt de ce petit
parcours qui aura avant l'atelier c'est
vraiment aussi de découvrir ce voyage à
travers le temps qu offre le château de
rambouillet effectivement on va
découvrir des panneaux de marge sur une
salle renaissance on va découvrir de
magnifiques sculptures de boiseries du
xviiie ou des décors peints de l'époque
de napoléon enfin c'est justement aussi
essayer de se refixer un petit peu sur
la chronologie de l'histoire qui est pas
toujours évidente
voilà il ya très régulièrement chez vous
des activités comme ça pour les enfants
alors ce qu'il y aura des petites
exclusivités pour ce week-end des choses
ouverte aussi peu souvent
alors là pour ce week-end on va vraiment
se centrer sur les décors du circuit de
visite mais on attirant l'attention sur
des choses que normalement on découvre
pas où on ne voit pas au premier regard
donc ça va être la chose la plus
importante par contre pour les vacances
scolaires
don qui suivent derrière les vacances de
la toussaint là on organise plein
d'animations différentes des enquêtes
policières qui font remonter jusqu'à
l'époque présidentielle
ou alors des visites avec une petite
sorcière qu'on appelle la sorcière
karaba pour les plus petits qui va les
transformer en petits monstres à faire
peur
là des animations beaucoup plus original
et qui vont faire découvrir des espaces
qu'on ne découvre pas en temps normal
alors on parle d'enfants depuis le début
mais ça s'adresse à quelle tranche d'âge
c'est plutôt les plus jeunes les
préadolescents alors pour ce week-end on
est plutôt à partir de huit ans parce
qu'on a la pratique artistique
donc là il faut une certaine dextérité
par rapport aux outils qu'on va leur
mettre entre les mains mais par contre
pour les vacances scolaires on organise
toujours de temps de découverte un temps
pour les petits les 4 6 ans le matin et
un temps pour les 7 12 ans l'après-midi
alors il faut s'inscrire j'imagine que
les places sont chères il ya quelques
créneaux bien numéro un c'est ça alors
oriane c'est vrai que du coup comme on
est quand même assez limitées en termes
d'espacé et qu'on vise absolument la
qualité du moment donc on veut pas la
voir des groupes trop important il faut
vraiment réservé les parts elle place
les places partent effectivement très
très vite
donc si sûr rambouillet tirer
réservation arobas monument tirait
nationaux.fr ou au 01 34 83 00 25
merci à mme claire à vérone donc en ce
premier week-end de vacances
laissez vous tenter par les décors du
château de rambouillet monument jeu
d'enfant c'est les 19 et 20 octobre et
toutes les informations ont été données
ce week-end c'est aussi la première nuit
des châteaux une centaine d'entre eux
ouvrent leurs portes ce samedi 19
octobre et dans les yvelines le château
de dampierre vous invitent à déambuler
dans son parc pour assister à sa mise en
lumière et des lampions seront
distribués
un dernier rendez vous toujours côté des
châteaux à breteuil la troupe du crâne
va vous conter les aventures du chat
botté
le célèbre conte de perrault et mis en
scène par monique fonds didion
l'histoire est contée ce dimanche 20
octobre à 15h30 et 17h30 hameau de
cinéma à présent quoi voir dans les
salles saint-quentinoise en cette veille
de vacances de la toussaint
hugo basse carl de l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois on a une
petite idée
écoutez
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la vie les
clayes-sous-bois nous avons un avant
goût des vacances scolaires avec en
sortie nationale
la deuxième aventure de shaun le mouton
ou la ferme contre attaque
l'avant première du film abominable et
le fameux film culte de steven spielberg
ready playerone que nous vous proposons
en ciné débat le mardi 22 octobre à
16h30 dans le cadre de la semaine de la
parentalité
nous vous proposons également à lisser
le maire à mettant en scène fabrice
luccini et anis démons anaïs des montier
est également nous vous invitons de
venir voir le film donne moi des ailes
de nicolas vanier une aventure
palpitante et merveilleuse que vous
ferez a traversé les cieux et les mers
du nord en ulm aux côtés de jean-paul
rouve mélanie doutey lui wacquez et bien
sûr des oies sauvages
vous pourrez retrouver ce film la
semaine suivante en compagnie de joker
jay minimale terminator fine ou encore
angry birds
[Musique]
un autre rendez vous pour les enfants
les petits comme les grands
l'association breezy vous a concocté une
exposition sont % légaux pour ce
week-end une quarantaine de passionnés
va présenter des dioramas sur leurs
thèmes fétiches star wars harry potter
ou encore les super héros et cette année
les membres de l'association se sont
lancés sur une grande création autour
d'un thème
écoutez son trésorier où on décide de
mettre en avant une petite m
pour pour faire quelque chose d'un peu
plus grand que les autres nous cette
année on a décidé de mettre en avant le
train on a prévu un circuit à peu près
25 mètres de long où on va faire
circuler des trains si possible dans les
autres dans les dioramas deux exposants
et si vos vacances débuté avec le soleil
du gwoka une expression artistique de la
guadeloupe
la maison de quartier théodore monod de
guyancourt vous propose des ateliers d
initiation à cette danse antillaise
deux ateliers sont prévus pour les
enfants de 8 à 11 ans à 14 ans et les
adultes à partir de 16 heures
un rendez vous organisé à l'occasion de
la journée internationale de la
eng et de la culture créoles qui a lieu
le 28 octobre prochain
la ville propose d'autres animations
écoutez pas réglé en cours important
aussi c'est d'ouvrir sur le monde en
fait les habitants et la culture créoles
fait partie de la culture française
nous proposons également une soirée
créole donc le 25 octobre pour tout
public où là les habitants de guyancourt
pourront découvrir cette culture à
travers la danse le chant la musique
mais aussi la cuisine
ce week-end c'est aussi les journées
nationales de l'architecturé à saint
quentin en yvelines deux rendez vous
sont proposés pour cette quatrième
édition le musée de la vie vous fait
découvrir la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines et vous invite à cheminer au
tour du réseau hydraulique qui
alimentait la demeure royale de louis
xiv
[Musique]
on débute avec un anniversaire celui du
trade et sept hameaux la course nature
de l'entente athlétique de 51 minutes
célèbre cette année sa dixième édition
pour l'occasion deux parcours ont été
pensés 19 et 35 km départ du circuit le
plus long à 8h30 et on parle maintenant
du côté du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la 103e
édition de l'open de france a débuté
aujourd'hui sur les grimm de l'albatros
le public pourra notamment voir les
golfeurs français victor dubuisson ou
alexander levy ou encore victor perez on
attend près de vingt mille personnes sur
sa date automnale inhabituelle pour cet
open de france programmé généralement
pendant l'été on écoute le directeur du
golf national paul en minute
c'est différent parce que on est on est
pas du tout à notre date depuis 15 ans
dans l'habitude d'avoir le dernier
week-end de juin au premier week-end de
juillet et là on est mi octobre donc ça
nous change au niveau de la physionomie
un peu au niveau des vêtements par
exemple
mais mais franchement il ya de quoi
amusé et occuper le public qui vient
[Musique]
venez explorer la terre telle que les
cartographes la représenter il y a
quatre siècles globe le monde à portée
de main montres des objets uniques de la
cartographie dont deux clubs historiques
présentées pour la première fois depuis
leur restauration
un sujet de nos confrères de via grand
paris une manière inédite de voir le
monde bien avant google maps découvrez
l'art de la cartographie des 17 et 18ème
siècles au musée des arts et métiers
jusqu'au 19 janvier prochain
ben lobb le monde à portée de main
présente des objets de collection rare
compas sextant ouvrage d'époque nous
replonge dans la lecture des terres et
des océans
mais les stars de l'exposition ce sont
bien sûr les globes cinq pièces uniques
dont deux en particulier du célèbre
cartographe willem bleus eux
présenté pour la première fois depuis
leur restauration du globe
hollande est élu début du xviie siècle
d'un dénommé bleus eux qui étaient
cartographe qui a travaillé pour la
compagnie néerlandaise des indes
orientales qui était le cartographe
officielle de cette cette compagnie qui
a été un des plus grands producteurs de
cartes et de blob host et xviie siècles
en hollande c'est à dire un les plus
grands producteurs de cartes dans toute
l'europe
tu as donc c'est double hommes ont été
restaurés elle était auparavant
complètement noirci on poussiére est
abîmée des traces de doigts installé
dans le parcours permanent
l'exposition est une immersion dans
l'univers de bleus eux grâce à des
installations numériques en trois
dimensions le visiteur peut manipuler
comme il l'entend les globes du
cartographe ces deux globes sont
d'ailleurs bien différents l'un et
terrestres l'autre céleste ils offrent
chacun des nouveautés inédites pour leur
époque par ce qui est un petit peu
génial avec bleus eux c'est à dire c'est
à la fois quelqu'un qui a fait des
études d'astronomie auprès de tycho
brahé dans une île suédoise où il à
cartographier le ciel c'est la première
fois depuis mille ans quand on avait une
cartographie précise du ciel et c'est ce
qu'on retrouve sur le blog céleste
en ce qui concerne le globe terrestre on
va voir les nouveautés des découvertes
de nouveaux continents et notamment
c'est la première fois que sur ce bob de
722 et représenter le cap horn
loeb le monde à portée de main est à
retrouver jusqu'au 19 janvier
c'est la fin de cette ut loisirs merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
ouais
on